okay i'm gonna start recording oh [ __ ]
balls balls balls balls balls
i tried to get it out before oh no it's
fine it got caught in there you got your
balls
in my let's play i got my balls cotton
you're recording you've got
your balls in my let's play you got your
lights playing my balls
wait a minute it's delicious
what is happening who's shooting it why
this is starting
warm-ups this is this is starter island
for this game
this is okay there's a starter island
that makes you have no idea what you're
doing dude yeah
no i don't i've never played this all
right so
same thing map you pick a space you go
there
it's great i suggest we go to
oh [ __ ] i mean there's gonna be [ __ ]
pretty much everywhere we could try and
go down to flush factory
yeah let's do that let's let's
definitely do that oh what are the
buttons to
do is that your space to jump bass to
jump
like it says on the screen one
go the the the parachuting
glider mechanic is way different than in
pubg so you can
open and close your glider as much as
you want yeah should i you guys are
going faster than me should i open it
you gotta like hold w wade are you
holding double i'm holding w
pointing are you aiming where you want
to go away well see the thing is
like it was ended up like that other
game the glider's got something
glider's got some [ __ ] and horizontal
like movement
like you can glide across the entire map
if you wanted to a lot of people
jump like immediately after you can just
to like glide to wherever the [ __ ]
so there's a guy southeast of us i don't
know if you see that guy
i don't yeah i see him he's southeast of
he's got a he's got a friend right up
here with me i'm landing on the roof
closest yeah cool
you got a gun there yeah i do it's an oh
there was another guy there was another
guy that was uh north
of us yeah well it's squad so there's
wow that was a long fall whoop wait hang
on oh
oh my god i'm gonna die
oh no he got me wait help get him going
ah
i got killed finishing i'll beat him
with the
avengers god i don't know how i killed
him oh [ __ ] i don't know how i got
killed there that was really stupid to
me all right yeah sorry
i thought you were like okay but we fell
through that roof yeah it took like
so much damage yeah i did not expect
that i i like lost all my health on that
fall and
uh and then then like i i i
should have just gone up behind him
because he didn't see me and i should
have just gone up behind him but i
shot him like a fool just to do a
play-by-play of how much i sucked i hope
this makes a lot of sense to you guys oh
i'm with you yeah what the hell do we uh
do now
okay wait you've played pubg like a lot
like i know you have
yeah but i mean this is the same as that
except it's just a different game so you
get guns
yeah shoot at people with those guns oh
[ __ ] you found the [ __ ] thing that i
was trying to find oh it was on the roof
i got juice yeah drink that that gives
you shield
yeah so there's chests and you can
always hear them by the
sounds yeah that's just like regular
fortnite i remember that
oh my god is anybody else getting just
like the worst performance ever right
now
no i got you buttery smooth baby no no
i'm
always good good performance janky and
oh it's because everything's on epic
cool oh yeah all my settings are
probably there too
oh yeah mine are too brilliant medium
let's go
let's go on high let's do that so should
i start harvesting materials or
focus just on there are people here so
for now
we should try and find chests and loot
guns i can't see the map
so i have no idea where find these
[ __ ] to fight them and so we can just
get like mark back
because well can we get him back no i
mean just die and then get mark back
yeah good luck good luck with you i was
a fool
without him thank you that's all is that
a guy there's a guy over here
by me wade okay there's another guy to
the right
right outside to the right to the right
to the right shoot him
shoot him wait this is burst fire please
shoot him
continue shooting him oh
you guys really cocked it up didn't you
you're really
boney guy that killed you yeah
whatever i'm just saying i'm not saying
i didn't [ __ ] it up i'm just saying that
you guys also cocked it up together
we're like three [ __ ] in a blanket you
know
like just cockiest blanket that's ever
caught cocking it up
all over the place just slamming her
yeah oh that's good sound yeah thank you
that's what i like
all right cool cool cool this is good
that's pretty good yeah
i hope that gave the proper illusion of
the [ __ ] in the blanket that we are
hey wait why did it turn me to the asian
guy
you guys seeing this some
maybe it knows something we don't
the biggest secret of our collective
lives
is that i've been asian this whole time
oh
what i know i know i'm massive take that
back
it's true you know look into your heart
you know it to be true
no all right where are we going i don't
know
i like tomato town all right let's go to
tomato town
just do this now to tomato town all
right you got it i'm going like right
now
hopefully this time i'm already gone we
landed in a we landed in a place that
didn't have any of our uh
our allies in it so hopefully hopefully
this time we'll actually get some
buddies of ours oh baby baby
baby okay there's there's two yeah
there's two other people coming down i
don't know if they're our teammate we
won't be able to tell
circle back for that brick house on the
they're they're going to whoa oh no
they're
oh there's a guy one of them is going to
the brick house okay uh well
good luck everybody i guess i don't know
what we're gonna do we're still going to
the brick
just no just playing together just land
why are we going to the brick house
i'm not here okay i think they might
have been our teammates because
it seems like we got some people here
they are teammates i see green arrows
awesome awesome awesome awesome awesome
okay yeah
so we're yeah we're with our teams
they're our teammates
they're really clever enemies who
painted green arrows over their heads
and they're like
wait this is way
like a minute they're just like all
right [ __ ] them
[ __ ] him literally [ __ ] him now
don't kill him just whip your dicks out
is that what this 50 50 mode's all about
yeah man
yeah it's uh 50 50 on whether you're
gonna get
[ __ ] yeah pretty much is is the full
title that they didn't tell you about
yeah there's no real way to like
sugarcoat it like our allies but they
took all our stuff
i got guns why didn't you get guns i've
got a gun and it's
not good yeah i have like a common
pistol i got a pistol and shut up
common i've got a common this that's
okay we can move on
where's the circle go okay actually
we're in a good place because we are
right where the circle is going to be
so keep an eye out because then there
might be a horde of like enemies coming
to this town but there also might be a
horrible thing i don't even hear any
chests
were there chests uh i didn't they've
already all been opened as far as i can
tell
huh well we could go over a brick house
i guess i think someone did that too
though
yeah they did so where do we want to
move to well you go to
wailing woods ooh great well to the
south of here are some mines that
sometimes have stuff in it but
they seem to be swarming that i'm gonna
go over to brick house to see if there's
anything that was
like looked over okay we're gonna head
south
now i'm going over to markwood okay
there's a tactical shotgun right here
whoever needs it yeah yeah usually like
i haven't
looting it yet it's it's there's one in
there in that door it's probably just
like a regular
it's probably just not oh it's a green i
guess that's not horrible yeah
people sometimes pass over stuff easily
i'm going to see if there's anything
hidden in the building materials
yeah so you collect building materials
by
smashing stuff up and you build things
obviously i said if we needed them in
this mode yes yes you're gonna want
you're gonna want a pretty good supply
of building materials
yeah so wood all sorts of [ __ ] brick
like once you get good at building like
you're very fast about it i usually set
up my
uh my wall to be a windowed wall right
away our friends are engaging
you guys want to come help yeah yeah
yeah i only got a pistol and a shotgun
i've got a submachine gun but it's
suppressed oh yeah i see him wait
i'm gonna push i'm gonna push this way
i'm building something real quick i'm uh
running with bob
okay i assume there's no reviving people
in this yes there is you can get them up
like pubg but you can't like revive
oh behind me yeah you shooting that guy
where there's a guy close there's a guy
closer
i didn't know you guys were over there
okay that guy's dead on the hill oh my
god there's so many enemies over here
yeah i'm running away i'm gonna die get
back to my fortification right here
yeah i'm gonna run back to marquez build
walls behind you as you run
and it'll it'll help like just with you
know not dying oh [ __ ]
ah help builders i'm coming i'm coming
i'm coming oh no they're
yeah they're def oh my god you're you're
boned yeah you're bone sorry you're
you're very boned well cool
ah no
remember me oh one i got one down
where are the other ones i was afraid i
was petrified
oh my god there's three more coming over
that hill oh my god
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa ah
[ __ ] didn't see those guys oh my god
those guys
just like [ __ ] swarmed us yeah that's
what happens like if the whole
team is there then it's just oh it's
just carnage
no no no you're still alive no no you're
finishing it
[ __ ] dude
[Laughter]
but you can see like you can see like
the fun of the game so
i would recommend like when things like
that happen definitely uh
appalling back and just searching bob
bob you were a lovely pink lady for like
a split second and then you went
like you switched to an asian person i
was bae penny
i wanted yeah let's uh maybe go
to retail row
i okay that's a little bit further well
a little
a little bit now we can get there well
no that's good it's good it's further
because it means less people
yeah something like that seems like
everyone automatically just jumps to the
very first town
and oh we're jumping jump wade
oh i pressed f crap
which one of these things is retail row
okay it's this yeah the far
one one
uh we got other people coming to retail
row i hope they're friends
there's a lot of them i'm going to land
on like the right side over here
i'm going to yeah right side yeah
i'm going to be like the second building
yes short of the basketball court is
that the one you guys are going for
wait yeah yeah yeah
oh hell yeah i'm gonna go further then
i'm gonna go back here
you're not a teammate oh you okay
there's a non-teammate here
run run before they get a gun he's in
this house i'm uh
i'm above him but i'm trying to gtfo
wait oh i found a chest
no just mine get the [ __ ] off of my
stuff that's right [ __ ] off you [ __ ]
all right where are you guys i'm coming
i went i'm west of you
i'll be there soonish shotgun man these
guys cleaned this place
out where's the enemy where's that enemy
guy he he was in this house i haven't
seen him
hey friend enemy enemy where i'm in no
no no he's a friend he's a friend
there's an actual friend
okay oh this is why you said friend made
it sound like
he hi pointing a gun no give me a
come on bud man this guy's taking all
the guns and [ __ ] i don't know how you
drop anything or else
like when i find something i would give
it to you i only have one gun though so
i think you can drag it out of your
inventory
when you're when you're holding all but
i'm fine i'm gonna push further and
towards waiting
we're doing surprisingly well yeah we've
got a lot of teammates in this area so
this is actually fortuitous
that is stressful you don't get to know
if they're teammates when you're
dropping though so you're kind of like
yeah oh seven teammates thank god yeah
exactly right
what a stroke of luck i could be dead or
it's just teammates i do hear shooting
yeah i do too i'm not 100 sure
from the west it seems like we're
winning because we just killed a few of
them
but yeah yeah they weren't jimmy poop
balls
not jimmy poop holes he's my favorite
poop hole
all right i got a gun set up good i
don't have a lot of ammo but i got some
gun i'm gonna meet up with you guys i'm
i'm nearest wade so that's where i'm
headed all right you guys find anything
else
no guns i'm harvesting i got a chest but
the chest only had a white m16 in it
that's fine
an m16 is a really good gun in my
opinion it's the best just because it's
like balanced and
good range [ __ ] and blah blah blah dick
a tree
yeah let the car exploding that beeping
noise
yeah when you harvest a car like like a
car alarm goes off
oh okay i guess i'll just keep loading
up on bricks and stuff
where's the circle it's right here yeah
it's right on top of us yeah and lots of
allies
is good what did that car ever do to you
kill it all right i've got a i've got a
good bit of
metal what's a good bit i i haven't
played this game in so long i've got
like 200
200 usually is good number cause there
everyone else also has a bajillion
things
i can just let my team carry me you're
saying yeah pretty much
all right this town has been scavenged
to all hell so yeah uh
bob mark and i are toward the west side
of town now
we got more teammates coming up from the
west side as well
uh looks like we're converging the big
team this might be
this might be good for us yeah i see
four guys west side
coming like northwest of town and you
guys have five guys trailing you right
now
plus me if you guys oh yeah they're all
out here in the wilderness if you guys
need smgs there's some smgs over here
i would like that just to have like more
bullets to shoot yeah all i have is one
gun still
yeah they're still in there are they
like right on you right now yeah
usually actually what'll happen is uh
teammates are actually pretty nice about
this they will drop guns that they don't
need there's um there's an smg a pistol
and an m16 here bob i took one of the
smg's i'm gonna take an smg okay our
guys are pushing north where are you at
right now
i was just talking about it he was in
that house that we were at yeah just
checking the roof to make sure no one
got it but someone did of course
it's 39 to 27 they've lost a good bit of
people so
it looks like we're gonna have the
advantage by no doing of our own
yeah hey we we landed
i have 200 stone and wood
look at all these boots on the ground
there's so many boots
[Laughter]
did you see the new brushes
it's really funny actually i don't think
i've ever seen a brian regan
anything really oh man you are not a
friend anymore
whoa all right well i'll just go this
way you're right then watch brian
rigging oh [ __ ] someone's shooting
someone it's the guy on top of that uh
building in the depot i'm sure the depot
has been claimed
like tall heck but i'll run through it
just to see but
which who is he shooting who yeah i see
like
built uh stuff all over the place
there's dudes up in there
and it's hard to get loot in this [ __ ]
you like yeah
you die if you let your friends like
nope there's nothing left
anywhere have fun with your
there's more submachine guns in here you
get more ammo if you pick up more
submachine guns
uh i don't think so i think each one
comes with one clip in it but i don't
know if that counts as more ammo for you
to like reload into your other gun
yeah yeah all right it looks like the
engagement is happening north
for some reason they must have all gone
to anarchy acres
that's my oh yes new circle though we're
on the
oh yeah we're on the cusp
i'm going to go over here and see if
they're they're coming because if they
are in anarchy acres they're going to be
all charging from the north what the
hell is that that's the storm that's a a
drop
no that oh behind us if you look uh
195 there's like a balloon that's like a
care package oh they do have drops in
this game
oh that's so nice mostly i think the
care packages in this game are like
this uh building materials but i think
they do also spit out like a gun or some
blue juice or something that'd be nice
sometimes yeah i don't like being
without a shield out here but
oh do you need some oh no you whoa whoa
where we got someone's shooting what
what's this guy
whoa what if they just what the [ __ ]
whoa what the [ __ ] i can
shoot the balloon and make the care
package drop faster
who the hell is ziggy why don't i know
things i don't know
i'm not culturally like that wasn't
significant it's not the word
everyone's rallying to the balloon wait
what the [ __ ] i just said i'm culturally
relevant
how do i know things yeah everyone's
rushing
i don't know why let's do it oh we're
down 30 oh my god
our team's dropping like flies all of a
sudden yeah there must be they must be
going for the balloon
don't worry we'll get there after it's
all over we were up like 39 to 24
weren't we
yeah yeah they're here they're here
and building walls so just start random
spam building is that what you're saying
i mean if you want yeah that's it's
definitely a strategy
oh jesus christ whoa what they have they
seem to have rocket launchers
yep that they do okay they're yeah
they're building up a storm on the other
side over there i think they got the
balloon which means they probably got
the heavy ordnance
well that's our team right there whoa
there's a bush
yeah there there's a bush whoa whoa whoa
yeah
whoo these guys are trying real hard
it's not a sniper rifle i'm a field oh
for god's sake get the revive i'm a
field medic
oh oh that's my building you just snip
sniped oh my god these revives take
forever
yeah these snipers are no joke ow
owie owie owie these snipers are not
joking around here
no they're not why don't we ever find
you okay
come in which direction do you know i
don't know i've got walls around me
though
i'm fairly safe okay i don't know where
that came from
i got bandages i got you
no one built a door in this thing oh
i've got a med kit is there a way i can
drop it for you uh let me
here let me hold all and try and like
drag it out of your inventory you can
drop it but i don't know here let me
let me i can hear you bob are you on me
yeah i know this
thank you yeah either one of those is
good oh jesus okay
jesus christ yeah this is where it gets
scary it's a [ __ ] war zone
oh my god yeah
this is like a world war ii battle scene
in in the form of a hilarious looking
cartoon
you have to say the whole world is like
fall [ __ ] fall [ __ ] fall [ __ ] fall
[ __ ] yeah
yeah i got one he was building a
staircase to know where they are
yeah they're all south not enough guys
oh i had their own gun out this whole
time
guys are using my stairs wow
ow you all right you're right i got snip
sniped from uh
yep that'll happen all right okay you
guys believe in me
because i've got an insane strategy that
i do sometimes you guys want to
follow my lead uh you ready i'm just
having fun existing and being alive but
okay here we go
i'm just what i do is i just run and i
build walls in front of me
and i just kind of like create this oh
[ __ ] someone's hitting me from ah from
my left from my left
where the hell would that come from
they're way to the left oh jeez oh jeez
i'm dead i'm dead
ah [ __ ] yeah they're they're yeah
they're definitely on the left in the
trees i believe
oh oh there was a sniper shooting yeah
those are the guys that are picking all
of our yeah i'm all the way dead
yeah somewhere to the left farther left
than those guys
yeah you knocked him good
nice nice nice nice nice i am out of
good ammo
that's all right there's a lot of
corpses in the field i'm going to move
i'm going to move up to our house yeah
wait good [ __ ] wade
damn these these the other team really
pulled it out of their ass to get this
like underway like wow
yeah i don't know how that happened but
they really really pulled it together
god these snipers are so snipey
yeah it's the people in the trees to the
left i know that for a fact
yeah oh [ __ ] oh god they're [ __ ]
it's the apocalypse in here
all right you gotta go oh i just think i
just took a that was a pistol
yeah oh god those are definitely rockets
come in here wade come in here i got you
i got you
that's not a pistol a true friend a true
friend this is awful
cover me red hot this is so chaotic i
[ __ ] love this
i know right because you'll get like
shitty matches where you die like right
away but then you'll get the matches
that are just like
oh i'm trying to finish him
i'm trying to build us more cover okay
oh look at all that ammo that guy
dropped
oh tempting wade right where
hey hey i did that
where's their ammo i need ammo so bad
all over the field but good luck getting
out there oh yeah see
wade i built that wall i built that one
to it i built that whoa
i did even in death i protected you i
feel very secure right now
i'm coming way don't worry wait if you
wait look behind you
look behind you there's a series of
walls that i built to get to that point
you see
how that goes yeah i do
i think your guys are done for you guys
okay bob i'm behind wall number two
wow oh bob you're down who's the hell is
building
wow
[Music]
watch your language
excuse you there's seven of us alive but
they're like oh
right yeah oh geez wow yeah they flanked
the [ __ ] out of us
whoa
yeah what we should have done is we
should have probably fortified the depot
itself
that would have been smart buckybots has
this don't you
bought built like it was already up
there fully fortified
oh hell yeah oh boy oh [ __ ] oh he's
gonna explode now
buckybot is doomed no you got this
bookie box
they're they're just gonna slowly
destroy your entire [ __ ] place
let's see what's going on with tenable
acorn ah i see
yeah [ __ ] knocked out randis beau bandus
tenable acorn is just hiding in a bush
what a [ __ ] oh they're down though okay
yeah they're down they're down we got
foo
up oh [ __ ] that's scary get him
oh sweet misses ah too many misses
uh i'm dead all right just bucky butts
1v12 buckybots you got this bucky bobo
you will be forever immortalized where
everyone will immediately forget that oh
[ __ ] oh no that's a shitty shotgun
oh great dirt feet one dirt
chicky yeah i can't believe they turned
that around that is
very impressive that was bad yeah
bye